were you nervous to do your freshman
freestyle
hell yeah
all of us was yeah when you gotta do
freshmen
you go there that morning first of all
all of us have to agree on the beat okay
so everyone's got to be like yes
everyone's got to be like yes and if you
ask don't say yes and you get
outnumbered yes it's grass okay so y'all
have to agree on to be
that morning you have to do a freestyle
a cipher so those are already two wraps
two different wraps
um
they have an abc segment they have a
read read hateful comments segment long
day i have to do photo shoots so it's a
long goddamn day
type of me i get ready like a girl so i
have to get glam makeup done all that
[ __ ] um you go do your different you
gotta have like three browsers different
photo shoots and all that so you doing
photo shoots throughout the day
different content pieces and trying to
write two raps that you got a goddamn
remember right and you got to kill it
and you got to kill it yeah so it's like
you kind of you kind of
write you got to recite a rap like
if alice if i listen to my favorite song
10 times i could rap it better that
tenth time than when the first time i
heard it so it's like you kind of gotta
go out there and wrap your [ __ ] with
confidence like you popping your [ __ ]
knowing them wearing your hair you don't
even gotta remember the lyrics because
you just wrote that [ __ ] right and you
gotta remember too you gotta remember
your freestyle and you gotta remember
decipher yeah
crazy who are you in the cipher with it
was me dolce doctor is dope as hell
incredible shout out to tampa
um
[ __ ] casey
casey
from new york i think from jersey
somewhere up there and i forgot the
other boy name
were you um like
thanks so much
sometimes we hear stories people do the
freshman shoot and then collaborations
end up happening after because you hang
out with them all day was there anybody
who you linked up with who you kind of
caught a vibe with there douchey dochy
she's incredible she by tampa yeah shut
up so funny because i look that
delicious like a pop like kind of poppy
and then we was at the thing she was
like hot so i put this ass out i was
like ooh florida you from florida that's
florida put that house
yes hosa florida says house
[ __ ]
is is i know jit's a florida thing but
is jit like tallahassee a florida thing
like what's that does it get i'm saying
does it get up to tallahassee because i
know it's like heavy like in the tampa
area yeah
what's that whatever oh we call it is
that that's my cheek